bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france alors jusqu'à présent on
valérie pécresse était à 10% environ des
intentions de vote dans les sondages
elle gagne donc sept points ce matin
c'est une évidemment une photographie
aujourd'hui je le précise avec ses
marges d'erreur mais quand même comment
expliquer cette cette dynamique selon
vous jean philippe dugoin clément
il ya un phénomène assez normal plus
tard il ya aujourd'hui une candidate
déclarée une candidate officielle
jusqu'à maintenant d'être dans un
entre-deux il y avait une primaire avec
plusieurs candidats maintenant les
choses sont claires on sait qu'il y à
une alternative potentielle à la haute
et kenda macron qui se termine sur un
échec qui se termine sur une action qui
sera mis sur des promesses non tenues et
il ya une dynamique de rassemblement qui
massent créé autour de valérie pécresse
c'est un rassemblement qui va faire avec
les candidats de la primaire et qui doit
permettre de porter un projet alternatif
pour enfin être dans le faire sortir de
cette espèce de volonté permanente
afficher une espèce de en même temps
mais où on fume il ya pas grand chose
qui est fait c'est ce que valait la
porter dans les semaines qui viennent
alors on va en parler valérie pécresse
qui a été reçu hier par par eric ciotti
dans son fief des alpes-maritimes on va
le voir d'ailleurs on a vu une photo
d'un déjeuner convivial entre entre les
deux
un déjeuner entre les gagnants du
premier tour à la primaire alors est ce
que c'est une unité affichée forcé ou
pas tommaso votre ski qu'en pensez vous
écoutez non c'est une belle image
d'unité après on va voir la suite des
requins promis un petit retard à
l'allumage on va dire mais c'était le un
peu le soir de la victoire où
effectivement sur le guantanamo à la
française dont eric ciotti l'a pas très
bien pris on peut le comprendre parce
qu'il ya aussi un passif mais la fin je
veux dire l'image dignité d'hyères on
peux pas la contester
il y avait au lendemain de du second
tour eric ciotti qui avait déploré un
mauvais message envoyé par par valérie
pécresse qui n'auraient pas suffisamment
repris ses idées comme la priorité
nationale par exemple voyez ce qu avait
répondu valérie pécresse et je vous
demanderai votre réaction suite jean
philippe du moins un clément eric ciotti
aura évidemment une place spéciale et
singulière dans ma campagne parce qu'il
incarne cette droite passe quoi que nous
devons mettre à l'honneur mon projet ne
sera pas édulcoré il peut être enrichie
pimenté mais pas dénaturée par les
propositions de mes autres camarades
candidats les militants ont tranché très
clairement pour mon projet janvier vue
du moins clément eric ciotti aura donc
une place spéciale et singulière
laquelle
je crois que je te le dire et le répéter
reste extrêmement claire et une primaire
cinq candidats chacun seront présentés
sur une plateforme sur un projet sur un
programme avec d'ailleurs des points
communs pour les cinq candidats on a
retrouvé certaines lignes de force entre
les uns et les autres maintenant l'heure
est au rassemblement ça veut dire que le
candidat qui arrive en tête a été élu
pas uniquement sur ce qu'il est mais si
c'est important mais sur un projet le
rôle de ce candidat c'est de venir
enrichir un projet en rassemblant en
rassemblant eric ciotti mais également
des trois autres candidats qui n'ont pas
accédé au deuxième tour mais qui ont
concouru qui ont rassemblé des suffrages
qui portent des sensibilités c'est tout
ce travail de rassemblement qui va être
porté par valérie pécresse dans les
jours qui viennent et bien évidemment
lexus qui est arrivé au deuxième tour il
aura une place
que hier dans le cadre de ce
rassemblement il incarne une sensibilité
de la droite qui a toujours existé
pourrait devenir ministre de l'intérieur
par exemple c'est qu'en cas de victoire
le lien évidemment non mais déjà j'en
sais rien je ne suis pas là pour choisir
à la place de la candidate je pense que
le salut les postes qui ne serait pas
reprise pas avant une élection générale
ils partagent pas les choses des
élections élections ça se gagne une
élection me faut se bagarrer pour aller
gagner une élection c'est quelque chose
qui n'est jamais gagné d'avancé
et moi je crois profondément déçu
question philosophique ni que les postes
ne se prépare tâche pas avant même
d'aborder y est parce que c'est le
meilleur moyen de ne pas gagner
d'arriver à l'échec quand on commence à
se projeter sur une élection avant même
de la voir jouer et bien aux filles dans
le mur après je suis convaincu qu'ils
étaient libres et le tube qui a fait de
sa place elle a quoi est-il peu près
d'antibes discussions à voir entre lui
et valérie pécresse mais bien évidemment
il ya un rassemblement qui s'est
aujourd'hui l'objectif de ce
rassemblement c'est un permettent de
gagner et d'autres permettent que tous
les talents dont eric ciotti que
d'autres xavier bertrand chesnais
dernier philippe g20 font également
partie on pourrait en citer beaucoup
d'autres encore et bien que toutes ces
personnalités qui ont chacun une valeur
ajoutée pour notre pays puissent
travailler ensemble pour redresser la
france il ya beaucoup à faire mais
beaucoup à faire ça veut dire que déjà
c'est les 10 et 24 avril à fergie
l'élection et ça passe pas par des
répercussions de prébendes mon projet ne
sera pas dénaturer c'est quand même ce
qu'a précisé valérie pécresse un pur
répond eric ciotti aux inquiétudes
d'eric ciotti tôt mal je vote ce qui est
ce que vous faites confiance à valérie
pécresse à 100%
alors écoutez c'est une bonne question a
confiance mais au delà de valérie
pécresse je vais revenir un peu en
arrière parce qu'effectivement la
question c'est de quoi eric ciotti est
il le nom je pense qu'il faut revenir
juste un petit peu en arrière sur la
signification de cette primaire interne
ce congrès interne risque qui réunit 45
mille voix donc mon à collectif de dix
mille personnes donc je pense qu'on a
bien aidé à son soutien et qu'on a 35e
des voix des gens qui n'ont soutenu mais
surtout au début de l'année l'ailer avec
80 mille adhérents avec 45 de vote avec
ceux ci aurait gagné ce congrès on sait
très bien qu'une partie des cartes pour
été faite par des gens qui n'étaient pae
l'air et qu'au delà de ça parce que je
dirais que tu y avait aussi des cartons
pas car au delà de ça nous on peut aider
depuis longtemps pour une primaire
ouverte derrière cinq ans on avait
quatre millions d'électeurs non mais
attendez c'est pas sympa pour revenir en
arrière c'est que françois fillon forte
de la primaire avec 4 million de votes
d'être millions de votants donc si vous
laissez pas seulement d'ouvrir avec
ciotti c'est d'ouvrir à l'ensemble de la
droite qu'elle va faire valérie pécresse
est utilisée eric ciotti comme ça un de
ses meilleurs actifs pour aller parler à
tous ce parce que c'est 30 % des
électeurs français qui sont soit chez
aujourd'hui chez eric zemmour soit chez
marine le pen et si elle ne va pas leur
parler d'eux avec notamment les
questions de crédibilité qui ont ils eu
beaucoup d'électeurs ont été échaudés
par l'ouverture nicolas sarkozy 15 ans
après donc aujourd'hui la question c'est
est ce qu'on ouvre au centre avec des
gens qui sont mac compatible nous notre
collectif on est contre les alliances
avec macron donc est ce qu on ouvre au
centre avec des gens qui sont macro
compatibles ou est-ce qu'on dialogue
avec tout le monde dans une saine
concurrence pour effectivement le rôle
de la candidate des républicains et
d'autres particules et soutiennent c'est
d'arriver en tête mais on peut faire
cette élection en respectant tout le
monde où on peut retomber dans le piège
mitterrandien veut dire que dès qu'on
parle d'immigration passant un peu
fermes ont des desseins schiste je
dirais ricciotti ses prix comme des
volées de bois vert aussi à l'intérieur
donc si on reste dans le piège de sos
racisme on n'arrivera pas à mon avis
suffisante
second tour et on arrivera pas surtout à
gouverner a changé des choses qui
entraîne notre pays depuis des années
dans des choses assez compliquées et
dans l'immobilisme face aux enjeux de
civilisation de sécurité mais aussi
d'éducation et l'économie parce qu'on va
pas parler de l'immigration c'est un
sujet important mais c'est pas le seul
jean philippe dugoin clément réponse est
ce qu'il faut ouvrir jusqu'au macro
compatibles
mais il n'y a pas à ouvrir on va ouvrir
le père et pécresse et effet élu sur un
programme maintenant font sujet c'est de
rassembler c'est de rassembler avec ceux
qui ne se sont pas compromis qu'ils ne
sont pas dans des logiques d'être parti
pendant cinq ans gouverner chercher des
préventes cherché à aller parfois
soignées sur ce qu'ils sont en allant
dans un gouvernement dont il disait
beaucoup de mal avant qu'il soit en
place valérie pécresse un problème
aujourd'hui c'est de rassembler la
droite c'est de rassembler au delà de la
droite où les électeurs qui aujourd'hui
pense que la situation actuelle n'est
pas satisfaisante que le gouvernement
actuel c'est l'inaction plus à droite
mais passer chercher cette feuille
question c'est pas une pression de plus
en province et à leur sens politique non
non non le positionnement politique de
valérie pécresse idée extrêmement clair
elle a fait campagne sur une droite a
chuté sur un programme avec une part de
régalien assez forte sur une part de
libéral assez fort elle a fait une
campagne extrêmement clair avec des
propositions charpente est battu dans
l'ensemble des thématiques du champ
sociétal après le rôle qui est le sien
c'est de rassembler sa famille c'est de
venir enrichir programme des
propositions des uns des autres mais
vous savez que ce soit nicolas sarkozy
ce soit jacques chirac la droite ne
gagne que plante à les rassembler elles
ne gagnent que quand elle est rassemblée
sur sa droite sur son centre droit le
problème c'est pas aujourd'hui de dire
on élargit policière mais 7,8 régresse
d'une trés car culine d'opposition
président du luxe entend et on peu
pareil dans l'antre 2 on peut pas être
macro compatibles on peut pas être dû
d'humains soutenir emmanuel macron et de
l'autre soutenir valérie pécresse est
soutenu en alternance aujourd'hui ce
pour quoi on se bat au niveau national
c'est cette alternance comment la porter
dans les régions comme on l'a portée
dans les départements comme on l'a
portée au municipal et après des
victoires aux élections intermédiaires
on a une chance unique après dix ans dix
ans de pouvoir de gauche dans un premier
temps et puis une espèce de globules
gamme et crâniens et bien d'avoir une
alternance cette alternance et la chance
pour peu à voir si on est capable de se
rassembler autour d'un projet ce projet
porté par une femme et eric ciotti a
créé son propre mouvement au sein des
élèves l'annoncé dans un tweet regarder
avec vous et pour la france je lance mon
mouvement à droite je ne vous trahirai
pas ce que nous avons construit et
puissant je continuerai de porter votre
voix thomas votre fille comment est-ce
que vous interprétez cette création du
mouvement au sein du groupe l'est
républicain
voilà je vous dirais je ne suis pas le
pas je suis un soutien mais pas le porte
parole d'aristide je regarderai bien non
mais puisque ces jeux je pense qu'en
fait ça témoigne d'une chose qui veut
peser et 7 témoigne pour le coup ça fait
écho à beaucoup de militants qui se
sentent quand même aujourd'hui trahis
pas ce qui au début ils ont même voté
pour un congrès beaucoup des gens qui
était parti des verts ne puisse pas se
présenter deux groupes se comprendrait
que la pilule passe mal quand même
aujourd'hui mais au delà ça mais je vais
revenir ça c'est a dit monsieur du
bâtiment avec lequel on se connaît
puisque je suis élu de l'essonne
si vous voulez la question est les eps
les anciennes sur les trahisons
l'ouverture de sarkozy vous parlez des
municipales ou man libre de valérie
pécresse a soutenu au municipal louis le
roy alors c'est qu'ils président du
mouvement agir c'est à dire les élèves
sont partis avec emmanuel macron si vous
voulez il ya encore un an et en 2020
valérie pécresse soutenez des macros
compatibles donc c'est pour ça que
maintenant je pense que la réaction
d'eric ciotti c'est de dire attendez on
le passé c'est le passé mais maintenant
si tu me prends avec moi comme copilote
et pas dans le coffre de la voiture pour
la compagne il ya des gens qui m'ont
soutenu qui vont être à agir la majorité
parlementaire demain il faut qu'elles
intègrent des scientistes et donc la
question je pourrai progresser à
monsieur monsieur clément si demain il
ya quelqu'un qui est investi par à
droite puisque a pas de candidat et
l'air et que monsieur
législatives est ce que lui dit est ce
que valérie pécresse va continuer à
soutenir monsieur leroy et le président
d'agir ou ce qu'ils soutiendront un
candidat de droite cds chose c'est des
symboles importants sinon notre
département mais partout il va falloir
être beaucoup plus clair ici ou qu'avec
monsieur muselier dlr aussi lasse pas de
la faute de ben ari pécresse elle était
pas au bel air pour les régionales elle
a été beaucoup plus claire pour le coup
pour sa campagne pour donner des preuves
d'amour à eric ciotti donc je pense que
la création de à droite c'est le
réceptacle du futur preuve d'amour
concrètes ils attendent valérie pécresse
pour inscrire son socle son socle
électoral aussi peut-être des militants
et leur vous l'avez dit qu'ils avaient
de nouveau à adhérer au parti qui
envisagerait maintenant de rendre leur
carte ils pensent je cite que pécresse
est une éolienne et c'est ce qu'avait
dit aussi elles sont été réjouit
d'ailleurs marine le pen regardez
je suis malheureuse pour les électeurs
aient l'air car valérie pécresse qui a
remporté la compétition interne face à
eric ciotti au second tour et la plume
acronis tu des prétendants de la droite
dans la course à l'elysée jean philippe
dugoin clément et il va falloir quand
même rassuré ses électeurs il y en a
certains qui partent
donc en tentant de relier jeu tout
simplement il le fait quand on parle de
riels je pense que marine le pen un beau
potentiel la réalité et valérie pécresse
c'est qu'on a eu cinq ministres du
gouvernement contre ni aux élections
régionales ni la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est d'accord dit date qui
fait le plus peur au gouvernement il ya
dire qu'à regarder la violence des
attaques dont elle a fait l'objet depuis
samedi soir dimanche lundi de la part de
l'ensemble de des proches des
lieutenants des manuels macro pour
mesurer à quel point une peur du
gouvernement actuel de voir sa fin dans
quatre mois la réalité c'est celle là
alors après l'extrême droite cherchent à
caricaturer
c'est le jeu c'est toujours ce qu'a fait
l'extrême droite vous savez on est
aujourd'hui entre deux écueils une
extrême droite qui pose des problèmes
qui n'a aucune proposition concrète qui
n'a pas de solution et puis qui est dans
l'incantation et puis monsieur macro qui
ne fait rien la réalité c'est avec
valérie pécresse nous avons nous avons
nous a plu nous avons ya qu'à voir la
façon dont est traitée de france par les
gouvernements de manière systématique la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est exagéré
pécresse et la première opposante de
manuel da cruz vous avez oublié eric
zemmour qui est aussi dans la course il
n'y a pas que marine le pen et emmanuel
macron nadine morano d'ailleurs a
soutenu musqué a sauté michel barnier a
envoyé un message de soutien hier à eric
ciotti vous voyez ce qu'elle a écrit
merci à toi cher eric ciotti d'avoir
défendu ton projet avec passion qui doit
compter dans la reconquête à thomaz
bellucci alors elle a écrit la
reconquête on sait que c'est le nom du
parti d'eric zemmour comment est ce que
vous comprenez ce message ou alors non
je la jemmerais pas les messages codés
de nadine morano la france vraiment les
ordis lisant
à je ne sais pas alors là non je pense
qu'il faut pas pouvoir faire alors
peut-être là je mange je ne sais pas non
je pense qu'il ya un sujet moi j'avais
un sujet évoqué par rapport à eric
zemmour c'est la question la question
lui dit
on à celui il ya eu cette phrase d'eric
ciotti qui a dit jean christophe lagarde
ce sera sans moi donc du complément les
représentants de l'ue et au delà de la
ligne de lui dit abou riad el dine
plusieurs européiste et fait légitime
dans la droite celui qui incarne la
question monsieur lagarde qui menace de
mort il donne des phrases pour dire que
leur exil book mérite des balles dans la
tête et à villepinte se fait agresser
n'a encore jamais arrivé j'ai été
important je pense que lui dit va régler
aussi la question de son leadership
si elle veut être dans l'alliance parce
qu'il ya quand même une question enfin
fut certes lagarde mis en examen pour
détention d'armes légales chez lui la
femme des choses un pont pitt est je
pense plus des mérites mieux voyez
beaucoup des u10 qui irait mieux
monsieur lagarde je pense qu'il serait
important plus pourquoi pas c'est
important aussi d'aller chercher des
électeurs que je vais pas appeler
d'emmanuel macro millions ont été
tentées par e-mail patron quand certains
hésitent aujourd'hui il faut aller les
deux côtés moi je dis pas qu'il fallait
que à droite val et de tous les côtés
d'avoir sans doute à centre à centre
droit un peu plus présentable
c'est vrai qu'il ya des électeurs au cnr
qui sont partis chez chez eric zemmour
et comment comment les récupérer jean
philippe dugoin clément alors répondu
aussi à ce qu'a dit tomasevski sur sur
lui dès il va falloir aussi clarifier sa
position et accepter peut-être de
récupérer des électeurs d'eric zemmour
déjà personne n'est propriétaire de son
électorat heureusement et valérie
pécresse ne gagnera pas ça ne va pas
récupérer des gens qui ont voté marine
le pen qui pourraient voter zemmour qui
ont voté malgré le maquereau parce que
la réalité on gagnera sur son socle
stricto sensu extrêmement restreinte
concernant la question du pays
jean christophe lagarde une phrase
malheureuse il s'en est excusé c'est
quelque chose qui est déphasé par
rapport à son parcours et un stylet j'ai
pas remarqué que monsieur ciotti soient
gênés du soutien de meyer habib député
rudy était sur tous les plateaux de
télévision premier rang derrière lui qui
montre que globalement en dehors des
croche-patte où on arrive à avoir des
logiques de rassemblement extrêmement
large et demandé à tous et très
honnêtement cette élection avec demba
sont incapables de regarder deux jambes
regardez vers ce qu'on peut construire
et pas de ressasser des aigreurs des
choses du passé très clairement mais
encore une fois c'est évident une
élection présidentielle c'est pas une
élection municipale c'est pas une
élection locale elle se gagne si on est
capable d'élargir son cercle quand on
prend des victoires électorales de
jacques chirac de nicolas sarkozy pour
parler des deux derniers présidents de
droite ils ont gagné parce qu'ils ont
réussi rassembler bien au-delà du champ
politique et ils ont réussi rassembler
les électeurs qui a eu différentes
sensibilités c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'incarnation du pouvoir c'est ce qu'on
appelle la rencontre entre un homme ou
demain je l'espère une femme et un pays
pourquoi avoir annulé le meeting de
campagne en présentiel de valérie
pécresse hier le gouvernement n'a émis
aucune restriction pourtant pourquoi
quand pensez vous est-ce que c'était une
sage décision thomass de vote ce qui est
sage décision je pense qu'ils effectifs
à moi ce que je rendais je vais vous
dire c'est d'avoir pris un peu le
prétexte sanitaires pour l'annuler a
émis tout à fait comprendre que valérie
pécresse d écouter ce ce meeting était
prévue une semaine c'est un peu trop tôt
on a besoin d'organiser les choses pour
que je prenne tout le monde le deux
rassemblements oui mais d'avoir pris si
vous voulez le prétexte sanitaire alors
que franchement on aimerait d'ailleurs
moi j'aimerais beaucoup en 30 heures au
sein du parti libéral-démocrate épris de
liberté
que on arrête avec le comment dire la
récupération de l'enjeu sanitaire par le
gouvernement qui essaie de faire taire
tous les autres sujets pour se poser en
garant d'une épidémie dont ils exagèrent
largement la dangerosité aujourd'hui si
vous voulez quand les républicains biais
ou de dire si pour des raisons
sanitaires nous on est responsable pour
décale ça s'est un peu c'est un peu
maladroit je trouve après je pense
qu'effectivement après le meeting de
force d'eric zemmour hier café gère tous
les observateurs qu'ils soient
journalistes de droite n'ont en tout cas
du monde voit la ferveur effectivement
moi je pense c'est logique de décaler
plutôt le meeting pas non plus n'a pas
pourtant je pense qu'effectivement la
prochaine en date les républicains
n'avaient pas le temps de l'organiser
sur un point pour être prêt je rappelle
d'ailleurs que hier olivier ubéda le
directeur d'événements de d'eric zemmour
a revendiqué quinze mille adhérents un
meeting réussi pour eric zemmour est ce
que valérie pécresse avait peur de ne
pas être à la hauteur selon vous jean
philippe dugoin clément
bombe absolument pas ensuite on ne faut
pas confondre vitesse et précipitation
n'est sur une élection de quatre mois et
demi la campagne pour nous elle a
démarré depuis le mois de juillet et une
époque où un grand monde aurait misé sur
valérie pécresse voilà faut dire aussi
les choses
on va être bien sûr mais le binôme de
deuxième tour personne ne l'attendait et
lé mythe c'est une bonne chose ça montre
que les élections ne sont jamais faites
ne sont jamais fait d' avance ensuite
faut pas content bottes faut pas
confondre vitesse et précipitation va y
avoir une montée en charge qui va se
faire dans les semaines qui viennent il
ya eu contexte sanitaire général qui ont
cliqué un miti c'est aussi on l'a vu
avec multi dernier mot c'est aussi quand
on accueille des milliers de personnes
c'est bordé un certain nombre de choses
en terme de sécurité et je pense que
tout ça effectivement que justifiée peut
justifier il n'y a absolument aucune
urgence sur ce faire que l'on prenne le
temps de faire les choses correctement
la priorité cette semaine de valérie
pécresse c'est de rassembler c était d
hier et du jour de la semaine de passer
la journée avec eric ciotti dans le sud
sur ses terres symboliquement c'était
quelque chose d'important elle va avoir
une semaine qui va y consacrer plus
largement au rassemblement avec les
autres candidats et la réalité c'est
qu'il ya aussi un agenda bien calendrier
politique on peut on ne peut pas tout
faire et bien faire en même
temps on verra il reste peu de temps je
voudrais juste une réaction thomass de
vote ce qu'est nicolas sarkozy a
félicité valérie pécresse mais ne lui a
pas apporté clairement son soutien
qu'est ce qu'il faut c'est pas renoncer
pas un bon message
je pense que c'est plutôt bien pour
gripper le crès puisque nicolas sarkozy
est certes très aimé dans le mitan mais
il est comme le responsable d'avoir fait
revenir kouchner donc je pense que bella
était gaza plutôt de la chance de ne
d'être autre chose que la ministre n'ait
plus la sarkozie merci beaucoup merci à
tous les deux en tout cas d'être venus
débattre ce matin en direct sur le
plateau d arte france par skype merci